nina schenk und natürlich beschäftigst
du dich auch mit dem thema nämlich
bewohner ja absolut es ist mir eine
herzensangelegenheit immer wieder über
kinder zu sprechen und heute habe ich
eine schlagzeile in der welt gefunden
die mich sehr gefreut hat uns zwar keine
über sterblichkeit in deutschland
bedeutet also wir im letzten jahr keine
über sterblichkeit hatten im vergangenen
jahr sind nicht mehr menschen gestorben
als ohne virus zu erwarten gewesen wäre
das ist jetzt keine nachricht um ihr zu
sagen cola ist harmlos aber es ist die
nachricht um zu sagen die panikmache
jetzt ist endlich schluss wir brauchen
den freedom day und hört auf mit der
punk ja da kann ich auch genau in das
gleiche horn stoßen wir reden jetzt seit
über einem jahr über impfen nicht impfen
testen genießen jetzt muss endlich ein
zeichen gesetzt werden wenn unser
gesundheitssystem nicht mehr die
belastung ertragen muss weil viele
menschen in deutschland
gelesen oder getestet sind oder auch
geimpft sind dann muss da auch wieder
geöffnet werden und dann müssen auch
wieder müssen auch wieder
veranstaltungen zugelassen werden ohne
die maske weil er muss man das ja auch
honorieren sonst bringe ich auch
jemanden dazu sich impfen zu lassen sie
uns mal ein bisschen mit wieder sich die
stimmung bei der polizei entwickelt hat
wenn es sehr spannend wer mit der
hochphase von corona erlebt die
polizisten plötzlich alle menschen im
park jagen mussten ja dass ich nicht an
die krone regeln gehalten haben was hat
das mit polizisten gemacht dass sie
plötzlich für ja diesen freiheitsentzug
in vielen bundesländern eingesetzt
wurden naja ich bin mir ziemlich sicher
dass die kollegen das nicht nicht nicht
gerne getan haben im hamburger stadtpark
beispielsweise wenn sie darauf
angesprochen haben es war halt eine
umsetzung der ordnungsbehörden und es
sind regeln festgelegt worden die dann
eingehalten werden müssen und verstöße
selbstverständlich auch sanktioniert
werden das ist nun mal der job der
polizei das macht kein mensch gerne aber
es muss eben halt sein weil wenn ich
wenn ich keine wenig regeln aufstelle
und die mich kontrollieren dann heute
auch gar nicht aufstellen das
massengeschäft wahllos kontrolliert oder
nein
nein wahllos wurde mit sicherheit nicht
kontrolliert also wenn man glaubt dass
der klare aufträge für die polizistinnen
und polizisten
konnte nicht lange begehen wie wir
wissen hier
und da wurde sich über karl lauterbach
unterhalten oder wie war das denn
wirklich so easy wie das alles aussieht
wie sehen die mir meine eine anstieg der
korona infizierten um 40 prozent oder
mehr als 40 prozent innerhalb einer
woche wir sehen kreise in bayern über
300 jetzt incidents werden das ist schon
ziemlich viel viele menschen sind
geimpft deswegen ist der verlauf nicht
so schwer aber
man ist zumindest das deutschlandweit
schon wieder 1600 menschen auf den
intensivstationen sind die menschen sind
jünger diesmal das heißt sie sind
robuster sie leben länger aber sie
hätte ich das wollte ich auch endlich
vor klopfen hätten in gewisser weise die
intensivstationen weil sie da lange
liegen und es wird nicht weniger wochen
es wird weniger wochen nur sein bis
wieder menschen ihre operationen werden
verschieben müssen weil die
intensivstation voll sind mit krone
patienten die vielleicht gott sei dank
nicht sie haben werden die aber da
liegen und da stellt sich schon die
frage ob wir nun auf diese nur auf diese
über sterblichkeits zahl gucken können
oder ob wir nicht auch sagen müssen dass
man auch frauen die zahl derer die da
auf den intensivstationen nicht und die
inzidenz werte die beschäftigen uns auch
ein bisschen und machen uns sorgen das
sind ja zwei themen also erstmal die
instanz werte die steigen gestimmt wenn
man sich das nach altersgruppen anschaut
sieht man auch ganz klar und das einzige
was ich für gefährlich halte einen
anstieg bei den über 80-jährigen letztes
jahr haben wir nicht geschafft die alten
zu schützen da schaue ich jetzt auch zur
union rüber das muss dieses jahr besser
werden die test strategie hat letztes ja
nicht funktioniert ich hoffe dass dieses
jahr davor gesorgt ist für die anderen
altersgruppen vor allem auch wenn man
schon impfung hatte ist es aber nicht so
gefährlich und der zweite punkt ist was
bei den jungen selten erwähnt wird sind
auch die vorerkrankungen die muss man
auch sehen wenn zum beispiel jemand 30
jahre alt ist aber schweres asthma hat
dann ist er natürlich auch gefährdet hat
war und als aller drittes reich möchte
ja auch die zahl hier richtig
kommuniziert weil die über sterblichkeit
muss man natürlich auch sagen es gab so
gab es zum beispiel auch weniger unfälle
wir hatten natürlich auch lockdown also
dadurch ist natürlich auch die stadt ich
kann in anderen bereichen runtergegangen
ich finde dass die zahl aber schon
exemplarisch zeigt dass wir keine über
sterblichkeit haben und damit auch keine
überforderung des systems hatten und da
wir jetzt weiter sind können wir nicht
in meinen augen fast dieselben maßnahmen
wie letztes jahr eine eine spannende
frage totalen den da wirst du ansprichst
die maßnahmen wähler jetzt haben ja
eigentlich ganz ganz viele politiker
ausgeschlossen in den vergangenen
monaten das ist eigentlich jemals wieder
ein lockdown geben wir zumindest einen
lock down deren das erinnert was wir
dort erlebt haben hättest du es für
vorstellbar dass olaf scholz als kanzler
mit den grünen und der fdp vor allem
noch einmal so harte maßnahmen verkündet
nein halte ich nicht viel vorstellen ich
glaube das ist nicht durchsetzbar es sei
denn ich leide jetzt wirklich schwarz
immer so schön sagt und alle
ministerpräsidenten der länder oder bis
auf vielleicht ein zwei fordern dass ein
und dann würde es eine solche
möglichkeit geben aber ein unter
gegebenen umständen selbst bei incidents
werden von 500 600 700 mit ist nicht
noch etwas passiert dann herzlicher
wachsam herr amt sollte auch würde auch
rechtlich nicht gehen finde ich als dem
lock darum muss man auch sagen der war
ja schon beim letzten mal live
übertragen würde stärker werden für die
einzelnen länder die einzelnen länder
sind stärker dann in den gibt in beeden
stärker die möglichkeiten haben das
entspricht auch dem was in spanien will
ende der
epidemische lage lage schwieriges wort
und dann entsprechend wird es eine
übertragung an die länder geben die dann
wieder die buhmänner sind sie dann frei
und dafür auch von verfassungs wegen
zuständig sind muss man ja sagen ist
rückkehr zum normalzustand was zum
beispiel in restaurants und so weiter es
gibt aus meiner sicht für so einen lock
down muss man ganz klar sagen lockdown
für geimpfte den wirt
verfassungsrechtlich nicht geben können
da sind die grenzen ganz klar ich glaube
und der nicht riecht also doch nach
österreich ich halte das auch für für
sehr bedenklich da muss ebenfalls aus
meiner sicht muss man sehen rechtlich
glaube ich muss man getestete weitgehend
auch mit geimpften in vielen bereichen
gleich stellen können deswegen finden
bin ich auch gespannt weil man sich
österreich anschaut diese idee des lok
downs für ungeimpfte mehr oder minder
hielt sich nach deutscher verfassungs
lage in einigen bereichen für schwierig
aber wie gesagt ich glaube auch und da
bin ich ganz bei den vorherigen analysen
wir sind jetzt nicht in einer
politischen debatten zeit wo es um neue
lok downs gehen kann sondern wo es darum
gehen muss wie wir verantwortungsvoll
durch diesen winter kommen aber trotzdem
freiheit eben auch als motiv im
vordergrund vielleicht auch wie die
chorakademie aufgearbeitet wird zb ich
finde ganz spannend auch die rolle des
bundesverfassungsgericht ich meine
laufen klagen wurden eingereicht schon
seit april gegen die ausgangssperren bis
jetzt gab es noch keine entscheidung da
würde ich zb als bürgerin sagen wann
kommen die entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts eigen ob
vielleicht doch die eine oder andere
maßnahme zu weit gehen wobei da sage ich
aber auch als derjenige der
verfassungsrechtler fraktion zuständig
ist es kann nicht sein dass wir ständig
alle politischen diskussion nun nach
karlsruhe tragen karlsruhe hat die idee
letztinstanzlich zuständig zu sein und
auch wenn es weniger
spannend klingt es dann vielleicht das
verwaltungsgericht in greifswald oder
sonst wo er erst mal der ort der debatte
und vor allem finde ich was mich nervt
in den ganzen debatte natürlich alles
nach karlsruhe outsourcen und da die
verfassungsrichterin auch politik machen
lassen was unsere aufgabe ist das müssen
wir ein paar momenten ist bald so genau
und das nervt mich muss ich sagen gerade
als verfassungsrechtler oft dass wir die
politischen diskussionen die wir führen
müssten viel zu oft nach karlsruhe
abschnitt wir dürfen aber auch äpfel mit
birnen nicht vergleichen zur zeit als
wir den starken lockdown hatten im
frühjahr 20 20 gab es noch keinen
impfstoff das heißt die inzidenz die
damals die damals diese höhe erreicht
hatten sind ja ungefiltert auf die auf
die bevölkerung gegangen und hat
infektionen ausgelöst heute haben werden
impfstatus von meine ich um die 70 da
ist die gefahr schlichtweg nicht mehr
dagegen gegen frühere oder wir sind
sogar schon über 80 in der bundespolizei
war schon mal über 90 sich da überhaupt
noch eine schwere infektion also in
schweren verlauf einzufangen und ich
glaube deshalb deshalb ist es auch so
muss da jetzt endlich mal schluss um die
debatte sammeln ich glaube auch nicht
dass die bundesregierung egal wie sie
wie sie aussieht dort in irgendeiner art
und weise noch mal wieder auf das
instrument lockdown zumindest nicht bei
dieser virus variante zurück
sehr darauf an wer am ende
gesundheitsminister wird wo wir bei der
beliebte frage sind
es karl lauterbach oder
deniz kadah würde villa widerspricht dem
jahr regelmäßig kanada hat ja schon
gesagt man darf sich nicht überschätzen
also insofern ist dass der finger
zahnweh und winter das
gesundheitsministerium die grünen an die
grünen und dann besetzt durch wo er war
war weil ich glaube schon dass ist ja
auf die person ankommt und wir haben ja
auch gesehen die kanzlerin auch darüber
wurde hier schon diskutiert wie
ängstlich sie noch ist haben wir in
brüssel erlebt wo sie ursula sondern ein
wir geben uns die hand gegeben waren
nach machen
das hat sie nicht getan aber sehr
zurückgezogen
haben sie auch schon einmal versucht der
kanzler die hand zu geben und hat sich
zurückgezogen ich finde das ist ihre
entscheidung wie sie es macht und aus
anderen gründen nicht die haben ein
scherz aber im zweifel ist so ich finde
es auch okay muss jeder für sich
handhabendes bleiben bei uns in der
fraktion jetzt auch wenn man wieder
zusammenkommt gibt es halt
unterschiedliche varianten der eine
herzt sich der andere gibt noch die
korona faust der nächste gibt sich die
augen und soll jeder machen und ich
meine die kanzlerin steht er unter
person morbach sie das erste mal mit
bändchen in den bundestag